because i didn't nervous i had a
breakdown such a psychotic breakdown
when i came out of drama school two
years out of drama school
spent two weeks in a mental institution
and um
it was tough you know i lost my mind
um and i kind of recovered from that
sort of got better put in a box
buried it for 30 years and a couple
years ago did a documentary
where i retraced my steps to find out
what the that was all about
um which was really scary and very
uh it was very scary time because i
as i said i i buried it so deep i i
didn't think i'd
ever find it but throughout doing this
documentary
it was suddenly right there you know the
pain of what
why i've gone crazy and and
it's just the reality of of having a
breakdown
you know really came home and that was
that was the uh my psychosis and me on
the bbc was that
me uh uh it was really tough the
toughest thing i've ever done
but i was given i was given my uh
medical records
uh during a sequence of filming
and um i couldn't look at it i i looked
at it once and it
terrified me it's a it's a record of all
the things i said
as i was crazy and it's really tough to
read
and uh i put it in an envelope
and i put it on the shelf at the back
there and i didn't look at it for two
years
and um when i
started to write this book i knew i had
to look at it i knew i had to look at it
so i spent six months with it looking at
it reading it
and it was scary but uh now that i've
sat with it
now that i've been with that pain and
been with that been with all that
confusion
all the stuff that sent me crazy it's
actually made me stronger i feel
better i feel like i got in touch with
the things that really made me
vulnerable the things that really made
me
uh that take me over the edge you know
and
you know i've sort of deciphered the
things that i'm saying sort of
almost like almost like how you can
interpret a dream
but but i i think i've sort of
interpreted the things i'm saying
it's been a really interesting journey
to
uncover your deepest darkest secrets
and um and to look at your crazy self
uh and sort of come to terms with it
and kind of and kind of hold it and not
be afraid of it anymore
and and i i feel as though
um i feel as though it's been a really
healing
process for me and now
there's not really that much that um
terrifies me or frightens me
or or um you know i feel i feel very i
feel very
in possession of of myself for the first
time in a
in in many many many years and uh i can
be really honest with myself
so i i don't think i could be before
um so so i feel pretty good about i've
been pretty good about where i am and
and
the work that i've been doing on myself
i still see a therapist
um that you know that sort of
that i speak to every week and that's
been really helpful
really really helpful and remember it
keeps me in touch with
the work on self and you know this could
be very isolating
you know what it's like when you're
working away you're in a hotel room or
you're in an
apartment somewhere and and it's even
it's even more crazy in kobe because you
know we're literally
we've kind of subtly been asked not to
go out or subtly being asked not to
go down and go to a bar or go to a
restaurant because you could catch
coffee
right so we're all sort of going to work
and coming home go to work come home
good work come on
and that's it that's been it for like
five months and it's been it's been
mind-numbingly
tough yeah but um
the book you know i sat here and i spent
my time writing the book and
and um and uh i've
it's been really i think this whole
period has been very has been uh
been very helpful for me to kind of get
in touch with something which is a bit
deeper
you